I thank you all
right was
okay folks uh couple of reminders again
you there are quite a few quizzes
upstairs still waiting to be picked up
at this point in time I've given up on
the alphabetical order because you got
the I've done it three times already
that's it I'm done right so find your
quizzes when you
can second if you've been looking at
your calendar your value valuation for
your feedback is due about a month from
today I think or less than a month four
weeks from today so try to get started
if you haven't already and if you have
and you're getting stuck kind of keep
moving right so today we're going to
complete the rest of the loose end so
start the class again let's do a couple
of tests let's say you've taken free
cash to the firm discounted them back at
the cost of capital and come up with the
value of 100 million what is that
measure it's a value of the operating
assets
in
your value the operating Assets in the
company let's say this company is dead
outstanding the face value of the debt
the book value of the debt is 100
million but the market value of the debt
is 80
million why would the market value debt
be lower than the book value what causes
that to
happen yeah one is interest rates going
up and the other is distress risk
increasing I can cause it so I have a
very simple practical question question
you got 100 million as a value the
operating assets you got two numbers for
debt Book value of 100 million market
value of 80 million which one should I
net out to get to My Equity value if I
net out the 80 obviously I get 20
million if I net out the 100 I get zero
or maybe the answer is somewhere in the
middle what do you think the right
answer should I subtract Book value
market
value should subtract market value okay
hold on to that thought this is one of
the messiest things in valuation and a
little later in the class we're going to
come back and talk about this because
you're right every textbook says
subtract market value we'll talk about
when you're going to be okay with it but
Sophia would you have subtracted market
value as well okay we and that's pretty
much every what every book suggests
we'll talk about when that might get us
into trouble and why you might want to
kind of deviate from the script
sometimes the other thing we're going to
talk about today is stock-based
compensation the most mangled aspect of
valuation that I see out there
the things that analysts do with stock
based compensation is mindball so let's
take a very simple example let's assume
you have a firm that you've estimated
the equity to be worth a billion dollars
and let's say this firm is 100 million
shares
outstanding let stop right there and say
what's your value per share the answer
is Trivial right $10 per share let's say
that you value this this company at $10
per share correctly and I now tell you
that the firm has granted 10 million
additional shares to its
CEO but I also tell you don't worry
because the exercise price has been set
equal to the value per
share essentially saying no exercise
value is nothing therefore what have I
given away nothing but I have a very
simple question what will happen to the
value per share with this additional
first let's get the side the direction
of what the effect is going to be we
giving these 10 million shares increase
my value per share or
decrease decrease because you gave away
something of value the question is how
do we compute that
decrease look at the choices here I'll
tell you how I came up with the choices
because they're all choices that analyst
make one is to count the extra 10
million shares in the denominator that's
called fully diluted shares which gives
you
$99 the second is to count the exercise
value in which case nothing happens to
the share price the exercise value is
close to zero therefore the third is the
correct answer is somewhere between $909
and $10 it doesn't do nothing and it
doesn't just increase the share count
today I'm going to give you I think what
the right way is of dealing with options
when you have options outstanding in
your company and we talk about why
companies have increasingly shifted away
from giving options to employees to
giving restricted stock okay what a
restricted stock there shares in the
company but what's the Restriction they
come with what do you not allowed to do
Sophia to trade them you can't trade
them the voting is unclear right I mean
that you know but the this you can't
trade them there's a liquidity
constraint so we'll talk about how to
factor those in so we've uh quite a
quite a lot on our plate let's go
back
right now when we talk about debt there
are two places in valuation we encounter
debt the first is in Computing cost of
capital we have to come up with the debt
to come up with the debt ratio in your
cost of capital and there if you
remember I said keep it conservative
don't count everything as part of debt
in fact I said count all interest
bearing debt and Lease commitments
because they meet three requirements to
that contractual commitment tax savings
and if you don't make the payment you
get into
trouble but you know some sometimes you
attempt can add the payable supplier
credit don't do it because if you do it
in the cost of capital calculation
you'll actually make debt a bigger
number you'll actually lower your cost
of capital because debt is cheaper than
Equity so you follow the rule you come
up with the cost of capital using the
strict definition of debt get the value
of the firm and now I'm going to give
you a Vari to the question but now I'm
going to make you make it even more
extreme you're valuing a distress
company you come up with the value of a
billion dollars for the assets the book
value of the debt is a
billion and the market value of the debt
is a half a billion why because it's
distressed very similar to the start of
the class test but I've added distress
the discount is much bigger okay if you
follow the script of a textbook it says
the value the equity should be worth a
half a billion right let's say you're in
acquiring company you decide to pay a
half a billion for the equity what's
going to happen the minute you
announce go up in
price your less exactly right if I'm a
healthy company I buy your company the
minute I announce that the Deb is going
to bounce back up from a half a billion
and I'm paying 500 million for something
that's worth nothing if you're doing an
acquisition
you can very quickly see why especially
you have distressed debt you might want
to go with the book value of debt here
rather than market value let's say
you're doing a liquidation
valuation what's a liquidation valuation
you're going to sell off everything the
company owns let's say you get 1.2
billion saying what do I need to
subtract out now what's the
answer will the bank take half of what
you owe them they know you're 1.2
billion in cash they're going to demand
the entire billion saying hey I don't
care how distressed you are we can see
the cash in your hands in liquidation
and in Acquisitions you should stick
with Book value why because it's a
clearer thing to do but if you're a
passive investor you're investing in the
company and the company is going to be a
going concern the market value argument
still applies use the market value of
debt if you're buying a th000 shares in
a company 10,000 shares in a company
because then you're hoping that as the
company fixes itself over time the
market value will go to the book value
but the value of the firm itself will
rise
so two sets of rules depending on what
you're
doing and we're not quite done this is
your last chance to mop up whatever else
is hanging over your head and I'll give
you two things that might or might not
apply in your
company you are you familiar with how
pension plans in the US are structured
Define benefit plans and Define
contribution plans anybody want to help
me out and what the difference between
those is what's a defined benefit whats
is a defined contribution plan want
try defined benefit CLA do you have any
ideas what is the defined benefit
defined
contribution the difference is most
plans are defined contribution plans so
you go to work for a company you set
aside money the company invests your
money you need get whatever you get
based on what it's invested that's a
defined contribution defined benefit I
promise you pension then I take your
money and I invest that money in stocks
or bonds and I try to make your pension
payment so the defined pension plan the
company actually has the obligation to
come up with that money you know there
are at one point in time in the US most
companies had Define benefit plans had
pensions now they've all shifted to
Define contribution I'll give you an
example Disney until 2012 if you join
the company before 2012 you actually get
a pension post 2012 12 it's now gone my
son actually joined Disney in 2010 he
goes one of the last generations to
actually qualify for a pension but if
you are an old company Legacy companies
it's entirely possible you have a
defined benefit plan you're saying so
what in a defined benefit plan you
promise to pay a pension it's a
contractual obligation for all those
employees who have retired right I look
at what you've set aside as money could
you have set aside enough yes but if
you've set aside too little you've got
what's called an underfunded p plan so
whenever you the words underfunded or
overfunded it's always a defined benefit
plan and if you're an equity investor in
a company with an undefended plan should
it affect you you have an undefended
plan tell me how what are the two ways
in which you can bring it
in it's underfunded right so you can
treat it like
that in other words do you have expected
cash flow over time you say if I'm
underfunded I've got to come up with x
million every year for the next 10 years
lower your future cash flow so you can
do one or the other but it can reduce
your value of equity because you have an
underfunded plan that's one thing to
worry about here's the other if you're a
company that a target of a lawsuit in
the US what company is
not you're investing in the equity of
the company could that lawsuit
potentially affect the value of your
Equity absolutely right you're reading a
case study of a of a SE seor that's
lived with this hanging over their heads
what be the
example farma but even before time
tobacco companies were the original
targets right because starting in the
80s and the '90s once said surgeon
general's warning went on those
cigarettes saying it can cause cancer
you had lawsuit after lawsuit after
lawsuit so tobacco companies and you
valued them in the 80s and the 90s this
was a constant issue value alria Philip
Morris it was then called find it under
value but before you bought the stock
you had to check you know how much could
this company have to end up paying in
legal obligations and lawsuits farmer
companies if you remember Merc had those
voo lawsuits for about seven years where
every month you'd have a lawsuit being
settled either they won or lost their
stock price went up and
down more recently I don't know whether
you you heard of a company called buer
it's a German Chemical Company and in
2016 in one of the worst Acquisitions
that I've ever seen they bought a
company called
Monsanto I'll tell you why it was one of
the worst Acquisitions ever they claimed
they they wanted to consolidate the
animal feed business that's what they
claimed the objective was but when they
bought Monsanto they bought themselves a
host of trouble that they could see
coming because already it was bro what
did Monsanto bring into the deal that
was potentially
prom every time you drive through
Suburban the Suburban in US you see
green Lawns everywhere right you saying
how come there are no Weeds on those
Lawns the answer is very simple it's a
product called
Roundup which landscapers in the US have
used for 30 40 50
years and over the last decade or so
you've had these probably more than that
15 or 20 years you've had these cancer
cases Rising where they've traced it to
round up so when buyer bought bought
Monsanto those cases were already
working the way and this is going to be
a mega mega mega billion dollar
problem it took buyer eight years to
extricate themselves from that problem
they had to pay billions of dollars but
they should have seen at least the
expected outcome coming when they paid
it up front you don't know how law cases
are going to play out but it's your job
when you are looking at a company and
you see lawsuits hanging over the
company to bring in that
expectation do you see what the justice
department announced about for Google
this morning
morning last year if you remember Lena
Khan did push in the they wanted Google
to devest themselves of Android and
chrome because they felt that that gave
them an unfair Advantage people assumed
that when the election was over that
that threat was gone this morning Sophia
what did they
announce that they going to stay with
that plan so if you're valueing Google
will this affect your value yeah is
saying that's going to be really
difficult to do welcome to the the party
this is exactly what you have to face
when you value Google so we have
lawsuits that you think will play out
affecting your value this is your last
chance to deal with them any questions
about debt and other stuff that you got
to clean up for for most of you it's not
going to be an issue but for some of you
this might be something to bring in
yes that's a good question this morning
in my Val my when I did my MBA valuation
class there were two people from the law
school were taking the class and why
they taking the class because they want
to be in investing why they want to be
investing because in I guess they make
more money as private Equity or hedge
fund than as lawyers and they want to
know what's a niche I can go out and I
just Niche which is if you're I mean
let's face it predicting how a lawsuit
will play out and how much is going to
get paid out is not a finance skill it's
a law skill you got to know how trial
laws work and how this process and
appeal process works and had created its
business and all you do is you target
companies that have become the targets
for big lawsuits and you track those
companies because the market overall has
no idea what to do with them so if you
win a lawsuit the price goes up you lose
a lawsuit the price goes down but if
you're somebody who truly understands
the pro process you will have an
advantage over the rest of the market so
can it be predicted yes but you need to
bring in skills from law school not
skills from business school which means
if you're Ving a company with a big law
suit find a lawyer friend asked the
question I have no idea because it's not
just predicting that first lawsuit
remember there's an appeals process and
what that appeals process would deliver
as a final outcome that's a really messy
process to get it but remember that's
where it's darkest that's why people
give up on these companies and you might
be able to get them at a bargain
especially after a lawsuit goes against
a company because people sell off this
is your time to get it maybe today is
the day to buy
Google is everybody selling off Google
this might be the time so I'm going to
assess the likelihood of this happening
and play it
out so now let's talk about Equity to
employees
yeah two question number one if a
company has St that is not follow if
it's private debt will I still take the
market value of that what does it matter
whether it's callable or not right
because the present value of your
obligations just got lower if interest
rates went up right so you're still
making the same payments I'm not saying
you're going to know not make the
payments but the present value of those
payments now is less than it was before
interest rates went down so let's say
you took the private debt in 2020 you
got a 3% rate guess what that that
coupon is low it's going to give you so
I'm giving you the advantage of the fact
that you have low interest rate debt on
your books because it does increase the
value of equity in your company
right yes
sopia pension or healthare in dep if
it's underfunded M but what do we do
with normal ignore it because in the US
it's a zero so if it's a if it's a
properly funded plan it doesn't affect
the value of your Equity right it's an
off balance sheet obligation that you
fully funded if you have an overfunded
plan and you're feeling daring you might
add it on as an asset just like you did
uh you know the Playboy Mansion you
could add on the overfunded pension plan
I tend not to do that because legally
it's very difficult to extricate money
from it so underfunding treat is that
properly funded you can ignore if you're
valuing a German company anybody valuing
a German
company what you'll notice is pension
fund assets and pension fund liabilities
find their way into the balance sheet in
the US it's off balance sheet only the
underfunding get show in the in a German
in a German system the the the
liabilities you have in your pension
fund are shown as a liability and the
pension fund assets are shown as assets
of the company so it's a mild difference
about the accounting that you got to
keep in mind let's talk about Equity to
employees I have a very generic question
you run a
business why would you pay your
employees with
Equity employ more it's an incentive
right you want them to behave like share
so part of it is you want to behave like
you want them to behave like owners so
it's kind of an extension of a profit
share what's the
other you don't have the cash right
let's be quite honest if you look at the
kinds of companies that use immense
amounts of stock-based compensation some
of you might be interviewing with these
companies they're going to be startups
lots of potential they don't have the
cash to pay you they can't compete with
a Morgan Stanley in terms of how much
they pay in cash but they can offer you
options or an equity stake in the
company so let's get that out of the way
companies don't Grant Equity because
they're feeling good they're doing it
because they want you to work for them
and this is their way of making sure you
do thank so in the next few pages I want
to talk about how to deal with
stock-based compensation not just
compensation that's been granted in the
past because remember you have two
issues to deal with one is this
company's been doing this for the last
six seven eight nine years you have this
dead weight cost of past option issues
past restricted so but they're not done
yet they might continue to do it in the
future and I want to keep those two
questions separate because they might
have to be addressed differently so
let's start with the easiest of the two
props if I'm valuing a company at much
rather value company which has been
using restricted stock to reward its
employees because it shows up as a share
count it's true that they can't trade on
it but it's very much like any other
share so one of the things I would
strongly advise you to do is because
companies don't count these shares they
keep them separate is you read the
footnotes they'll tell you how many
restricted Shares are out there add them
on to the share comp now one of the
things I've noticed when I go to Yahoo
finance or even Bloomberg and I look at
the share count many of these share
counts do not include restricted shares
and they Shar they're like any other
share the pro that the the reason I
think it's so much easier to deal with
stock-based compensation is the shift to
restricted stock happened around
2007 and why until 2007 did people Grant
options because accountants made it easy
and made it look like you were giving
away nothing CU until 2007 the way
accountants dealt with option based
compensation is they value the options
based on exercise value remember the $10
option Grant the account looked and say
you gave away nothing what's a million
times nothing nothing 10 million times
nothing is nothing so you could give
away a huge chunks of the company and
the accountant just stood by in 2007 the
accounting rules changed now when you
grant options what are you required to
do anybody know
yeah the treasury stock method no you
can't use the treasury stock method now
you actually have to Value the options
as
options and show them as expenses so now
when you look at the cost of good sold
for a software company in that cost of
good sold there will be a stock based
compensation and analysts don't like
this so what do analysts and companies
do they add it back this is a stupidity
right accountants finally do the right
thing what do analysts do they reverse
it
but that's the reason companies have
shifted away from option to restricted
stock you no longer have that freebie
that came with options so let's talk
about employee options think about why
first as a shareholder in a company when
a company grants options you have to
worry about it what's the what are the
characteristics that make for an
option it's got a finite
life you got a fixed price and right now
the stock price might be equal to that
fixed price but if the stock price rise
in the future you effectively have to
sell your shares at a discount right
that's really what creates this issue
with options it's not that you've given
options and employees can convert to
shares but you can sell it you have to
sell it at a discounted price so what
we're trying to factor in is how much is
that potential loss and value going to
come be you know is it possible that I
could Grant options they end up
unexercised yeah stock price drops an
option value tries to capture the
expected value of both of those things
happening so when you use an option
pricing model you're capturing an
expected value both the upside and the
downside file that away because I'm
going to give you a very simple example
and I'm going to use the three ways in
which analysts deal with options to show
you the different numbers you're going
to come up let's say you have a firm
with a 100 million free cash flow and a
cost to cap cost of capital of 8% and a
growth rate of 3% a year so that's going
to give me a total value for the firm of
two billion which is just some growing
perpetuity I subtract our debt I get a
value for the equity value of equity per
share this is the example we start with
right you give 10 million shares or
options in this company what will happen
to the value per
share one answer the accountant 2007
said nothing's going to happen because
you've given away nothing it's kind of
absurd because you go to the options
market and tries to try to buy an option
that's at the money and you say look I
don't pay for options at the money you
will never be able to buy that option
there's a price there's a Time premium
and you're ignoring it the second is
that the value per share is going to
drop by roughly 10% because there are
10% more shares out there and the third
is you got to Value this as an option to
actually figure out what you're given
away that's the answer I'm going to push
you towards but I'm going to take you
through the first three the first two
approaches one of which is adjust the
share count the second it's called the
treasury stock approach a lot of
analysts like and what you implicitly
assume there and then we'll look at the
right way of dating with options so
here's the first one it's called the
diluted stock approach what do you do
you take the billion dollars you got an
equity and instead of dividing by the
actual number of shares outstanding you
add the extra 10 million that will be
outstanding if the options get
exercised you preemptively are counting
those shares what does that do it
increases the share count reduces your
value to $99
you see what you're missing when you do
this even assuming that the options get
exercised which is already an assumption
when they get
exercised what does the option Holder
have to do to actually exercise the
options they have to pay $10 right it
seems to completely miss that because
that $10 is going to come in when those
options get exercised so what's the easy
fix for that what should what can I do
to the
numerator I can increase my numerator by
the $100 100 million that I'm going to
get and if I do that that's called the
treasury stock approach my numerator
increases by the proceeds and I divide
by the 110 million shares I get a value
per share of exactly $10 you see
implicitly what you're assuming when you
use the treasury stock approach you're
assuming that options are worth exercise
value you're missing the time premum so
the first approach the deluded stock
approach will undervalue your shares
because you're counting nothing the
treasury stock approach where you
effective count in the exercise proceeds
and divide by the number of shares will
overvalue the shares because you're
ignoring the time
premium which means that there is a
goldilock solution here right which is
if you can somehow value those 10
million options as
options and subtract them out from value
of your Equity you should be able to get
a much better value so here's the in my
view the right way to deal with options
that are already out there take the
option first value The Firm doing so
don't do any of this stuff differently
that you do in the first stage free cash
for the firm cost of capital growth rate
value The Firm subtract out the value
the outstanding R so far still what
you'd have done in any valuation but
before you divide by the number of
shares take the equity the options which
can include both management options and
warrants value them as options what does
that do it takes the exercise value puts
a Time premium
on value them as options subtract that
value from your Equity because you've
given it away and once you've done that
you divide by the actual shares
outstanding so don't adjust the share
count adjust the equity value for the
options outstanding why is this better
because it brings in the time value of
money it reflects the fact that the
options might or might not be exercised
and you no longer have to decide which
option to include and which to exclude
right all options will have value even
out of the money options this allows you
to clean up for
it but the only thing is you have to use
an option press ing model initially
that's what accountants gave us reason
for not doing this option pricing models
are really difficult to use not really I
mean they've been around for 40 years
you just plug them in but basically EV
valuing the options as
options now you've seen a couple of
option pricing models i' assume in your
foundations in corporate finance
class no you don't remember seeing them
if selective
Amnesia one is called the binomial model
the other is called the black schs black
schs is this model with all those terms
of nd1 XM so basically all these but
it's a it's a model that's been around
50 years Fisher black and Mar schs won
the Nobel Prize for it's actually very
straightforward model in terms of the
input six inputs value any
option but it's a model that was
designed to Value shortterm listed
options on traded stock so really
designed to Value option the this on the
Chicago Board of options
and we're taking those models and
applying them on tra on management
options and here are the things that are
going to stretch the model perhaps to
Breaking Point first is employee options
are not two month three-month options
they're 10e options the option pricing
models were designed to Value short-term
options why is it a big deal because the
black schs model assumes the variance
will not change over the lifetime of the
option not a big deal if you have
three-month options but much bigger
issue with long-term options second
when you exercise an option on the
Chicago Board of options nothing happens
to the share count it's a side bet that
you and I are making but an employee
option get exercised the share count
itself will change it's a delusion
effect that will actually reduce the
value of the option and we got to
somehow bring it
in third the black schs model was
designed to Value what are called
European options kind of an unfortunate
choice of word because it say something
to do with geography what's a big
difference between European option and
American options only excise European
options you can exercise European option
the American options can get exercised
earlier so even without going through
option mechanics American option should
be worth a little bit more than European
options because you get all the rights
that you get with the European option
plus this right to exercise ear the
black schs model was designed to Value
European
options and most of the time we get away
with it why because most options don't
get exercised early
I'm going to come back to you again why
why don't most options get exercised
already so let's say you made a bet the
stock price has gone up it was a call
option why would I not exercise you
exercise it early you destroy the time
value if you can sell it you can the
time value and that money to buy because
the options were designed for options of
CBOE people sold the option they didn't
exercise it on the Chicago Board of
options 95% of options get held till the
very last moment of the very last day
why because you give up the 5% is
usually around X dividend is not a big
deal so with regular options there is no
early exercise therefore you can use the
black schs model let's say you're an
employee at
Nvidia you were lucky enough to join in
2019 when the stock price was like $7
per share $5 per share even after the
price drop today it's about $110 per
share but are you getting a little
nervous about what the future might
deliver at this point those Invidia
options are now worth 2/3 of your wealth
in fact you borrowed money to buy a
house based on the invetor options you
have five more years left in the
option you see the Temptation here you
might there's no selling the option
these options are not liquid what's the
only way you can cash out you're going
to exercise the option early half of all
employee options get exercised early
many of them get exercised half way
through 2/3 of the way through because
you can't wait there's no liquidity what
does that mean if I use a black schs
model to Value these options I'm
effectively assuming they hold till the
end and they get exercised earlyer I'm
going to over so I'm going to affect the
value of these options because I'm
missing that early exercise so that
became the initial stopping block you
can't use option pricing models because
these options are different so what
happened was between 2003 and 2007 and
there was stock about value employee
options people started fiddling with the
black schs model to adapt it to value
employee option so I'm going to give you
the simplest way to deal with many of
the issues first when you think about a
black shs model and even if you don't
remember it there are five drivers of
the option value especially with no
dividence one is the stock price second
is the strike price the third is the
maturity the fourth is the standard
deviation the stock price the fifth is
the riskless rate every black schs model
requires that so if I use the
traditional black shs model I'm going to
use $10 as my stock price but here
here's the reason I might not want to if
I go out an exercise is optional the
stock price it's $10 it's at the money
but the minute I announce I'm exercising
the options what's going to happen to
the stock price it's going to drop
there's a delusion effect there's a
simple way to adjust for it I've reduced
the stock price for the delusion effect
so I've made it a model now that I can
value management options second if I
wanted to can I replace the maturity of
10 years with a shorter maturity
absolutely I can argue that because
these are employed options even though
there's 10 years left people are often
going to exercise in four five six years
I can use a shorter maturity with those
two fixes black shows models work
surprisingly well at Value management
options in fact I tried this on the $10
option that I just gave you the value
that I got per option was
$542 those 10 million option that I gave
that were at the money with the 10e life
are worth 542 a
pce 10 million time 542 is $ 54.2
million that's how much I gave my CEO
with an option Grant so if I now
subtract at the 54.2 million from the
billion and this is key once you do that
the number of shares stays at the
original count so don't double count
don't increase the share count for the
number of shares come from the option
subtract the value the equity options
the value per share you get is
$946 so if you remember the two extreme
values 909 with the fully diluted $10
with the treasury stock this is going to
put you somewhere in the middle and I
think it's a most realistic estimate of
what your value per share will be if
those options are granted any
questions yes in restricted stock we
that's a good question right did did
everybody get so I said restricted stock
are easy so if IID granted a 100 million
restricted shares all I would do is
increase the share count is that but
restricted shares you're not allowed to
trade those shares and if you're not
allowed to trade those shares they
should be at least in theory be worth
less than the unrestricted shares there
are people actually put a discount based
on what's what happens like 8% it's not
worth the effort I wouldn't even bother
just add all the restricted shares in
and leave them as a pile in terms of
share
count so with restricted shares adjust
the share count but with options value
the options subtract them from the value
of equity and take care of it much
cleaner
way now all of this that I've talked
about adjusting the share count and
value options is for options and
restricted shares granted in the past
but the company's not done right they're
going to continue to use options and
restricted shares in the future saying
what do I do about those future grants
and here what Warren Buffett said about
options I think is worth remembering
especially about employee options he
said we Grant employees options itions
because it's compensation and what do we
do with the rest of compensation
expenses where do they show
up my operating expenses they said well
I don't even know why there's an
argument about this employee options are
an
expense that you effectively have to
factor in when you think about how much
my company make that's why I've never
understood why there is so much
resistance to this
idea you know what are some of the
reasons analysts give for adding back
stock based
compensation because clearly they must
have some reason they act know so they
adjusted deit adjust
debit why do you think they what's
rashna it's
noncash I want you to get ready for the
counter because you're going to hear
this right don't subtract out stock
based compensation it's non-cash we're
treating like
depreciation what's the difference
though between depreciation which is a
true non-cash expense and stock based
compensation yes
sopia what stock based compensation
especially if I'm looking at the past is
basically pretty clear as well right I
gave especially it's restricted stock
pretty clear idea of how much I've given
away so
but restricted stock it's not right
options you can argue it's an option
pricing
model
yeah everyone so it is something it's
not a non-cash charge it's an in kind
expense let me explain let's say you own
a
pizzeria you have five employees you pay
them minimum wages because that's all
you can afford they're threatening to
leave and go work somewhere else so
here's the deal you enter into at the
end of every day you're going to hand
each employee three pizzas to take
home it's a non-cash expense right but
does it cost you as a business 5 * 3 is
15 pizzas soas you does it C of course
it does you're selling fewer pizzas
there's less so think about know
stock-based compensation it's more like
those pizzas you're handing your
employees rather than depreciation which
is a pure non-cash charge there's
nothing behind it so when you give away
pieces of the company which is my
company as a shareholder you give me
pieces of my company don't tell me that
you know that you're giving away nothing
because that's less of the company
that's available to me in the
1990s tech companies young tech company
the do boom 2025 30% of companies were
given away as option grants to to
employees and and after the fact you you
realize that that was a problem because
those option grants either got exercise
increasing the number of shares or these
companies had to buy back stock to cover
those option exercises out of your cash
flows so there is zero argument for
doing what we're doing with stock based
compensation of adding back the stock
based compensation it's not an expense
it is an
expense it might not be a cash expense
the conventional way but think of it as
just skipping a step if he had issued
the option to the market raise cash and
pay the employees it'll been a cash
expense you just skip that step so when
you look at at at valuing these
companies it looks like you're double
counting but basically you're dealing
with two separate issues a company like
Cisco has a huge overhang of options and
restricted stock from the past but it's
not quite done they're continuing to do
it so I'm going to punish them twice
once when I project out future revenues
and cash flows I'm going to have give
them lower cash flows and then after I
Valu the Equity I'm going to reduce the
value of equity even more because of all
those options from the past it's not
double counting because I'm dealing with
two separate issues one from past option
grants the other for future option
grants and you know that adjusted
earnings game it's out of control now
you take every company they have an
adjusted Abit they airb back stock based
compensation That's a classic and bunch
of other things and I think they're
playing to the I think the laziness of
analysts he's saying what what's the big
deal about Abid why do they pick Abida
to
adjust how do how do many analysts put a
pricing on companies it's an Abida
multiple right so if I know you're lazy
and you're focused on Abida guess what
I'm going to do I'm going to pump up
that ABA and that's exactly what they're
doing they're adding up de you apply
eight times AB now you're giving me a
much higher value because I add it back
so I think analysts get exactly what
they deserve but it doesn't mean the
rest of us have to play this game of
using the adjusted Abit D number
right which brings me to my favorite
part of this class goes back to that
very first session when I talked about
connecting stories numbers if you
remember I said a good valuation is a
bridge between stories and
numbers so as you look at your valuation
I want you to think of the story you're
telling me and I'm going to force you to
tell that story because that's what's
going to connect your numbers together
cuz left to your own devices you're
going to play to your
stret I'll tell you as a number cruncher
what I go back to and I'm I want to add
more decimals because I think Precision
it's called false Precision but you
think if you make it more precise you
feel more comfortable you claim that
you're being objective why because
you're using numbers as if using numbers
removes the being subjective and you can
say I'm never biased because I'm working
with numbers if you're a Storyteller you
have your own set of delusions right
including what you think if you tell a
big story I've got to give you a big
number could be a fairy tale but look I
told you a big story second storytellers
love anecdotal evidence they're like my
mother-in-law and I don't mean that as a
compliment now I remember this dinner
we're having in the middle of the dinner
she says it's a you know we're up in a
snowstorm somewhere she says the best
car to drive in a
snowstorm is a Volkswagen bug
the old Volkswagen Bug have you seen
these they're like 300 pound you can
lift the whole car and I said Judy how
do you come up with this crap and use
the word
crap and she told me she said 15 years
prior she had been in Lake Tahoe she'd
gone to the grocery store in a
Volkswagen Bug and you could see the
story kind of picking up
steep it was snowing she was driving
home three other cars went off the road
but she got home safely he says so see
that proves it right a Volkswagen Bug is
the best card to have in a snowstorm
amazing sample size of one how much you
extrapolated but storytellers love
anecdotal evage in 1997 I did this this
amazing thing happened therefore so when
you look at storytellers they are going
to kind of go crazy they they miss that
dividing line between reality and
fantasy because nothing is restraining
them so good valuation tries to fight
both those extremes
I also I think confessed early in this
class that when I started teaching
valuation I taught it like a number
crunch it did which is when in doubt put
up an equation you still doubt put put
up a second equation make them
simultaneous Sol makes you feel much
better even if it does absolutely
nothing it's only a few years into
teaching this class that I learned that
I had to teach myself storytelling so
I'm going to take you through this
process of going from story of of what I
do when I have to value a company
because I have to force myself to be
disciplined to go through this in steps
because if I don't I'm going to go to a
spreadsheet and start working with the
numbers so this sequence works for me
you might find something else it works
for you so what's the first step in
converting a story to numbers you got to
understand the company of valuing right
what it does what it sells who buys it
why why they like it who the competition
is what I so I call this surveying the
landscape but just a fancy word for do
your home work and much of it doesn't
come from looking at numbers it's from
talking to
people so if I ask you what makes Costco
special how many of you are Costco
members okay what makes Costco
special no no but think like a customer
right so they tell to ask youself why
would I go to Costco instead of Walmart
I like a free meal every time first is
there's always a sampling but the first
thing is their their controlled entry
right Walmart let's everybody in who
does Costco let in only members so
already a part of a club it's a very big
Club but it's a club cost you
$75 the prices are good and you're
already in there you're half a mile into
the store and you're saying I'm not
going anywhere else so you take 16,000
rolls of toilet paper and you know five
big bottles of olive oil but you see
what to to tell the Costco story it's
easy because you kind of understand what
the company does what makes them spe
let's face it Costco is one of the few
brick and motor retail stores that not
just survive the Amazon Onslaught but
has survived but has prospered so it's
worth asking what does Costco do so when
you value Costco that's where you're
going to start not with the financial
statements what does Costco do that
makes them
successful and then you get a bit of
story around that so first step in the
process is obviously understanding what
a company does
so I'm going to use an example and this
is an example from which one of my books
was born called narrative and numbers
it's an example that goes back about a
decade June of
2014 minding my own business reading the
Wall Street Journal actually reading the
physical Wall Street Journal I didn't
have the digital Edition then and I see
a news story about a company called
Uber raising $3 billion from Venture
capitalists who had priced PR the
company at 17 billion I'm using every
word here deliberately Venture Capital
price company 17 billion and I must
admit I was
surprised first I'd never heard of uber
he saying what were you doing living
underground yes I was technically living
underground CU I was in New York then I
would take the subway everywhere I never
took car
service I I should take that back I'd
seen the word Uber in my credit card
statements in the 3 months leading into
June of
2014 CU my second son who was going to
college in North Carolina was using Uber
and using my credit card to back it up I
don't know how this happened but I
thought he was taking German language
classes to be quite honest no uml out on
the you should have kind of given it
away so read the story about Uber
raising 3 billion being priced at 17
billion I need to know more about the
company I'm curious so guess who I call
first I call my son but he was still
sleeping so 11:30 in the morning but he
kept what I call College student hours
which have nothing to do with the sun
coming up and the sun going down that's
a different know different calendar and
he wasn't picking up his phone so I
called my niece who lived and worked in
Chicago and she was technically awake
why because she had a job horrible mood
and here's how she picks up the phone
says what do you
want I said have you heard of this
company go Uber she said it's a right
sharing company I said what the heck is
a right sharing company she said I don't
have the time to tell you why don't you
just download the app and find out for
yourself hangs up the
phone should talk to a mother about this
Behavior I haven't mentioned it but I
download the app sitting up in my
office and magical things start to
happen in my phone I see a GPS opening
up and a car trying to drive towards me
why in New York City you don't get from
point A to point B you just try go in
the general direction zigzag I see the
car zigging and zagging and I can see
the name of the driver George this has
never happened to me with the Yellow Cap
I'm fascinated I what George and the car
kind of find their way to 44 was Fourth
Street I ran out and say hi George I
told I wanted to show him I seen his
name he says you didn't enter a
destination where do you want to go I
said nowhere in
particular but could you drive me around
for about 30 minutes I have some
questions to ask
you he thought for a brief moment I Was
a Serial Killer but then he decided he
could take me he said get in the back
seat and I started asking him questions
I said this an Uber car you're driving
he said no this is my
car I said why do you do this he said I
have a job I don't make enough money at
the job I own this car it allows me to
earn a second income to supplement my
core income I said why do you need Uber
he said in New York City it's illegal to
stop on the streets and offer somebody a
ride it is illegal
actually Uber allows me to connect with
customers
so I kind of got why this guy was
driving for Uber it allowed him to take
a car he already owned and earned a
second income and Uber connected him
with customers he drops me off in front
of 44 West 4th
Street I offered to pay him he should
have just taken the money he said you
don't have to pay me I said it's free he
said it's not free do you enter a credit
card when you downloaded the app I said
yes I said what happens now he said they
will charge you and I said how do you
get paid he said they'll send me 80% of
the fair I remember asking why 80% he
said I don't know that's what they all
do and he drives off at this stage I
could see why Uber did what they did for
connecting cars to customers they got to
keep 20% of the fair which left me with
one final unresolved question why would
my son and my niece take over to give
you some background and my son he's
incapable of calling a Yellow
Cap a very primitive process right in
New York how do you call a Yellow Cap
you run out onto the street you wave
your hands
and you can see the guy changing for
higher not for higher for higher not for
higher then he drives right past you if
you're lucky he stops and then you get
and give him a destination he says I
don't know where that is can you tell me
how to get there it's almost like 18th
century technology I mean that's how we
probably called horse carriages in the
late 1800s my son is incapable of doing
that so I want to know why he would use
Uber right so I called him this time at
a civilized hour where no excuse for
sleeping 3:30 in the afternoon I knew a
basketball game had started I knew was
waking up for the game so I caught him
right at the start of the game and I
decided to put him on the defensive
right away I said I noticed you've been
using my credit card for your ride
sharing I acted like I knew what he'd
been
doing said why would you do that you
took a car down with you to North
Carolina why would you want to use a
right sharing company if you have a car
with you and he said dad on Friday
nights
and Saturday nights I really like
uber as a parent there's some followup
questions you don't ask but I kind of
guessed and I said that's interesting
what do you like about Uber he said I
can call the car from the bar I said
that's a plus I said you must wait
forever right he said no no they come
sooner than a cap it must cost an arm
and a leg right he said they cheaper
than a cap the cars must be filthy right
he said they're cleaner than a cap I
said let me get this straight they're
cheaper than a cab they come sooner than
a cab they're cleaner than a cab that's
what a new cab service was destined for
Doom and then the final question was
what's so special about Uber why
couldn't I buy a really powerful
computer take it down to my basement and
connect cars to customers and I could
think of two things Uber had that I did
not one was $3 billion they had it I
didn't what's your
other well it's not just a customer base
it's a fact that this is a a business
with sopia you want to try what is it
about that gives Uber an advantage over
any new
entr that too so there's a regulatory
Break The Rules first and then ask for
permission
later it's called networking benefits a
fancy word for now once you get big in
this business it gets very difficult for
a newcomer to break into here's why
let's suppose you have a car and you
want to drive for a right sharing
company you got Uber you got lift let's
have a new startup that I have
which one you know if I if I made you
pick are you going to go with the new
startup or you going to go with one of
the established companies why because
that's where the customers are if you're
a customer you can download one app on
your phone which one are you going to
get you're going to get the one where
the most drivers are it's a system that
effectively creates this Loop where
you're going to as you get loded so what
does it mean the end game in this
businesses you're going to have one or
two big players not 15 the economics of
the business
that was my research on Uber he's saying
why don't you look at the financials
what
financials company was a privately owned
company incredibly secretive there only
two numbers are new about Uber in June
of 2014 one was their gross bookings
from the previous year and the second
was how much money they
lost but let's assume I had access to
the financial statements for Uber what
exactly would have learn from them
there'd be very little there right the
financials for a young startup tell you
very little about the company it's like
a Kinder guarders report card right he
saying look should I set money aside for
college it's a little too early to make
that judgment what exactly in that
report card is giving you away
no so the fact that our financials
didn't stop me the other so as as I go
through you I'm going to try to build on
what I've learned about so the second
stop is you've learned it enough about
the company you now have to tell a story
about the company right well remember
you're not a creative novelist so as you
tell a story about a company don't have
people wandering in and out just you
have threee headed dogs you you're not
JK Rowling you don't need to write in a
500 page
story so my advice when you think about
a business story is first keep it
simple I'll tell you an example of a
story you should not be writing
20 years ago my oldest son gave me a
reading suggestion he gave me this book
was 1,200 pages long and he said dad you
got to read this book it's amazing and I
take my kids reading suggestions very
seriously and look at the front of the
book it says Game of Thrones George or
or Martin and I tried I read about
halfway through the book I called my son
said Ryan I'm too old for this they're
like hundreds of characters they wander
on they wander off they die they come
back to life they're good they're bad
I've kind of given up on this if you're
telling a business story don't make it
Game of Thrones you don't have eight
seasons and 80 episodes to tell your a
story of like 15 minutes keep it simple
second keep it
focused on what what's the end game for
whatever kind of business it is what is
the endgame for every
business well that's a very terminal end
game right but so but it
is you guys are giving all the I think
business school has ruined you there's a
syain stainability
answer there's the private Equity answer
give me a business answer what's your
end game for a business make money right
so when you tell a business story at
least tell me you've thought about the
possibility that you might need to make
money you know how many Founders pitch
their stories and about 20 minutes in
usually a tech because amazing software
I've written but 20 minutes in you stop
them and say that's really amazing but
how do you plan to make money I haven't
thought about that but let me tell you
how how great my softwares how many
people are downloading it I'm not
expecting to make money next year but at
least tell me whether you want to use a
subscription model a transaction model
because without a pathway to making
money you will never make
money keep it simple keep it focused so
I'm going to take my own advice and show
tell you the story I told for Uber in
June of 2014 I'm going to emphasize the
dates because this story obviously
shifted and morphed over time because
Uber has shifted and morphed over time
in June of
2014 my story for Uber and every word in
the story is going to show up in my
valuation as you track the words think
of how they'll play out my valuation is
that Uber is an urban car service
company you see already where I see Uber
succeeding what does the urban tell you
about where I see
success cities and Big
Towns as a Car Service
Company second which will expand the car
service business by bring bringing in
new users like
whom who did I say never take a Yellow
Cap people like my son younger people
who could not quite get this 18th
century technology of calling the cap
would be more likely to take third with
local networking
benefits talked about what networking
benefits are if Uber becomes the largest
car service company in New York there'll
be a Tipping Point where it'll end up
dominating the
market but in my story LIF can take
Chicago DD can take Beijing Ola can take
Mumbai and grab can take qual lur what
does that mean when I put market shares
for these companies for a global market
I can't give any of them 40% market
shares in my at least my local
networking story you could have eight or
10 different ride sharing companies
dominating different parts of the
world and I did assume in 2014 that they
could keep doing what they were doing
which is they didn't own the cars and
the drivers were not employees they were
IND independent contractors and that's
going to play out my numbers that's my
June of 2014 story it's more often
changed over time but that's where my
story
started so I've looked at the
landscape I've framed a story the third
step is to make sure that I'm not
deluding myself remember when you value
companies the person you got to watch
out for the most is not me or somebody
else it's you because it's easy
especially if you really like a company
or like a company to tell a story that
you don't think okay I'll let it fly so
I what I call the 3p test is it possible
is it plausible is it probable sounds
like I'm playing on words but each one
I'm upping the anti possible is the
weakest test basically you got to show
me it can
happen at least don't tell me a fairy
tale right if you can pass the test and
I say is it plausible has somebody done
something like this maybe not in your
business but in some other business
so I've up the IDE then if it's Pro then
ask is it probable you got to show me
proof that you've actually pulled it off
in some small segment of the market
possible plausible prob I've wrestled
with ways of trying to explain the
difference between these three words and
about 10 years ago I was in Latin
America doing a series of sessions on
narrative and numbers just this topic
and I had three City stop first first
night I was in sa Paulo Brazil second
night I was in Santiago Chile and the
third night I was in Lima Peru so I'm
doing the same presentation I'm saying
look I want to pick something first
night in Brazil where 300 Brazilians can
all relate to whatever I pick so if you
have to pick a topic that 300 Brazilians
will all have a point of view on what
topic would you pick Sophia football or
soccer 6 months before the 2018 World
Cup I ask a question is it possible that
Brazil will win the world cup you asked
300 Brazilians 6 months before a World
Cup is it possible that Brazil wi the
World Cup what do you think the answer
is going to be of course we've done it
five times before then I said is it
plausible that Brazil W the World Cup
you know what if IID asked that question
in December of 2014 that room would have
been shaky you're smiling tell me what
happened in 2014
again in a moment that they've kind of
erased from history 2014 there was a
World Cup in Brazil and Brazil played
Germany in the semifinals and one of the
great shellac Kings of all time so in
2014 they have said I don't know we play
but by 2017 they'd regained their
confidence they were second ranked in
the world yeah it's plausible then I
said is it probable that Brazil win the
world cup and then you could see the
wheels click it we're in the right group
and Neymar stays healthy and he doesn't
flip and flop or do whatever else he
does on the pitch if if if that
take your favorite sport and your
favorite
team is it possible that the Yankees
will win the World Series of course it's
possible for any team right right now
every team is tied for first place or
last place the season hasn't started is
it plausible do you see the new story
any Yankee fans
here do you see the new story
yesterday but Jared Cole Our Star
pitcher what was the new
story he might have Tom is it now deci
okay now you you made my heart drop for
little I'm holding out hope but he might
have to have Tommy John surgery which
means he's out for the season all of a
sudden became a little less
plausible is it probable you also lost
Stanton just a few couple of weeks ago
he's not coming back either all of a
sudden what looked probable at the start
just few weeks ago now is be that's
really what you're doing with the story
is you're passing it through those
tests is it possible plausible
probable so I'm going to give you
examples of impossible stories
implausible stories and improbable
stories so you can get a sense of how
far people
overreach let's start with impossible
stories you know you know what a
fairness opinion in an acquisitionist
what is a fairness
opinion an independent bank has to come
independ as in quotes a bank and what do
they have to
do in other words they got to do a
letter saying they pay know that you
paid a fair price and what do that how
does it help you as acquiring
company rather
ofal CL exactly it gives you protection
against so if you overpay and your stock
price drop 40% ster sue you can go to
the Delaware courts and say I have a
fairness opinion in fact the fairness
opinions were born out of a Delaware
courts op you know court case in the
1980s where the court said if you get a
fairness opinion and bankers sign off
you cannot be accused of fraud or
negligence because you did your due
diligence and of course that's LED rise
to fairness opinions that back up pretty
much every deal on the face of the Earth
it's where valuation first principles go
to die because as a banker you got to
justify the unjustifiable so usually
read fairness opinions for Laughs
because that's what they're good for so
this fairness opinion covered perhaps
one of the most conflicted deals of all
time the deal where Tesla bought Solar
City so let's see some let's do a test
who is the largest shareholder in Tesla
at the time of that
deal a guy called Elon Musk who's the
largest shareholder in Solar City at the
time of the deal a guy called Elon mus
what a coincidence same guy right who is
the CEO of Tesla at the time of the deal
guy called el musk who's the CEO of
Solar City at the time of the deal a guy
called musk with a different first name
who
cousin the time this deal was announced
both companies knew they were going to
get Su so they decided to buy protection
so each company goes out and hires an
investment banker Solar City hires
Lazard go to Lazard old time New York
Investment
Bank and Tesla hires
evocore a ique Investment Bank he say
what's a boutique Investment Bank it's
like a gastro pub you ever walk by
gastro pubs at airports don't walk into
them because there regular burger joints
where they triple the price that's what
the gastro I guess lets you do so
Boutique Investment Bank does what other
investment Banks do but they charge
three times the price and both
investment Banks go to work what's their
job to justify the steal it was an
exchange offer where X number of shares
of Tesla were being given so basically
both investment Banks had to go to the
shareholders of the company say you got
a good deal already you can see the
tension there so Lazard does evaluation
of Solar City or pricing of Solar City
and they do all the standard stupid
things like use a multiple for the
terminal value do a little dance and say
it's okay and Tesla's valued by ever Cor
in what I think is one of the hor most
horrifically bad discounted cash flow
valuations of all time so they take
Tesla and they project out cash flows
and the next 5
years and then at the end of year five
what did they do what what do we do for
closure EST estimated terminal value you
can see them reading out of a textbook
almost they put a Perpetual growth rate
of 6% a year forever in 2016 in value
Tesla my first reaction was what
currency are you valuing the company in
maybe Argentine pesos and you forgot to
tell me it was in US
Dollars the t- bond rate was 2%
you let Tesla grow at 6% a year forever
and an economy growing 2 to 3% what's
going to happen in about 10 15 20 years
it'll become the economy then we go
globalized right then okay then 20 years
later it'll be the global economy then
what I think we'll have to bring SpaceX
into the story and launch Teslas to Mars
right this is an impossible
story I actually so if you get a chance
you go and visit my my blog in 2016 when
the deal happened I called this the
worst discounted cash flow valuation
ever seen and for doing this piece of
crap you know how much aore got
paid $8.5
million there's no justice in this
world I actually was in evercore a few
weeks later at because I had to give a
talk get on the elevator and the three
Bankers involved in the deal got in the
elevator with
me I looked in the other direction and
said I don't see you guys you know they
saw me and they kind of knew who I was
so and they knew it's just a it was just
there was no way you could defend it
that's an impossible valuation second
you let your company grow but you let it
grow so much it kind of becomes uh your
market share is 150% we have a problem
because no matter how great your company
is your market share can't exceed 100%
I'll give you a story to illustrate
this now through the last 15 years
Netflix has been a favorite company for
people to value for lots of different
reasons so about 10 years ago Midway
through the semester I give this
feedback time again and I get know a
bunch of company company valuations and
one of them is a Netflix valuation so
take a look this guy's estimated value
four times higher than the market
price it's a company where you have a
tough time getting the market price he
four so I look through the numbers and I
look at his revenues in year 10 they had
600 billion in revenues in your 10 so I
emailed the guy and said could you
please come in I need to talk to you so
he comes in and he says what's wrong and
I said nothing but I want you to lead me
through this valuation I said do you
have Netflix he said yes they said how
much do you pay for year he said about
$100 I said I'm looking at your revenues
in your 10 you got 600 billion in
revenues how many subscribers would
Netflix need to have he pulled out his
calculator and I said you don't need a
damn calculator you got 600 billion
revenues you pay $100 a year you need
about 600 6 billion people subscribing
to Netflix he said I don't see where
this questioning is going I said hang in
there I have a couple more questions and
then we can let it go I said how many
people are on the face of the
Earth he say I have to check on Google I
said save you the time it's about 8
billion people is there something you're
not telling me maybe there's a law
that's been passed that says every man
woman child and pet has have a Netflix
account and they can't share he said
don't be absurd I said I'm not the one
estimating 600 billion revenues you are
so when you look at your revenues in
your 10 I want you to ask the question
are my revenues a number that I can live
with is there a market big enough to
carry it because sometimes you can get
carried away with those percentage
growth rates impossible
valuation you see valuation with people
cut cost when you cut cost will your
profit margin go up
yeah so your one your two then you get
carried away and you keep cutting cost
and cutting cost and your margin keeps
climbing just remember there's a cap on
that margin you can't cut cost one cost
go to zero new margins again stating the
obvious oh here's a very technical
impossible valuation I see lots of
banking valuations where capex and
depreciation are separate line
items with their own drivers and over
time depreciation depreciation actually
exceeds capex and they lock that in
Forever ever you see why that's
impossible what do you get to depreciate
whatever your cap exes how can
depreciation be 120% of capex forever
these are impossible
valuations let's talk about implausible
valuations implausible valuations can
happen but you got to tell me a really
good story something that backs them up
so it'll be an example of a company that
grows without reinvestment for a long
period how can you pull that off maybe
you're an infrastructure company you've
spent the last 20 years building toll
roads you can grow without reinvestment
for the next 10 15 20 years you have a
company with margins much higher than
everybody else's and no competition is
coming in so you better have a story
that fills in the Gap I remember valuing
a company called almarai almarai is a
Saudi Dairy company food processing
company and I valued one of the things
that jumped out in me the profit margins
for Al marai were about twice the profit
margins for other food processing
companies in the Middle East
I remember presenting this in Dubai and
I said look I don't know much about Al
marai but what do they do that allows
them to earn these margins that are so
much higher than everybody else's yep
sop what what do they
do Acquisitions actually push the US
when companies do acquisition the
margins actually go down so it must be
Acquisitions plus something else
right strawberry me date me
so one is they' have customized so how
come other people are not copying them
right milk is milk you can't patent
it saw
years that's my question why aren't more
new ENT so I asked listen to buy and the
person in the audience said did you
check who the top 15 shareholders in
alar
are the second on the list was somebody
somebody been out you got the Saudi
royal family as a protector it kind of
allows you to keep your competition R so
what you're looking for is Give Me A
Reason when you PL or if you can show me
a company that's earning High returns
with very little risk again I'm going to
push back tell me what's allowing this
company to do it maybe it's connections
with the government that allow them to
charge more than they should and allow
them to keep the rates high implausible
and improbable I'm going to introduce
what I find is a very useful device when
I look at
DCFS what I call a valuation triangle my
valuation triangle has three sides to it
one is growth the second is reinvestment
the third is risk so in about on March
April 3rd when you said in your DCFS I
think it's a Friday I'm expecting about
500 DCFS to hit my mailbox at about the
same time and I want to get them back to
you by Monday I don't want them hanging
over my head say how the heck are you
going to go through 500 DCFS I'll give
away what I'm going to do so I'm going
to look at your DCF yeah obviously you
picked a company I might not even be
familiar with the company on growth you
can give it high growth average growth
or low growth right so let's pick one
what do you so pick any one of those
three low growth so you pick low growth
I'm not going to contest you on it it's
your company if you have low growth then
I go check out what you're reinvesting
and if I have low growth what should I
expect to see in the
reinvestment low reinvestment and when I
look at your cost of capital your cost
of capital should probably be lower than
the typical company low low low make
sense high growth high reinvestment high
risk again makes sense what I'm looking
for is a
mismatch so if you have high growth with
low reinvestment low risk it can happen
but I need to know what your story is
for how this company's able to grow with
relatively low reinvestment and low risk
that's what storytelling does it fills
in the Gap says look I know this looks
odd but here's why my company can pull
it
off that's improvable
you guys watch Shark Tank okay it's all
recorded now you don't even have to
watch it live here's what I wanted to do
tonight pull up an episode of Shark Tank
preferably one which doesn't have Aston
Kutcher as one of the venture capitalist
right the traditional cast and you know
the format for Shark Tank is a Founder
presents a story and then the sharks
jump in so I want you to wait till the
founder presents the story then pause
that's the the reason I wanted to watch
the recorded Edition and think of three
questions you would ask the
founder to figure out whether the story
they're telling is possible plausible
probable what do the Sharks say what is
the typical question that sharks are
after
Story first is how much money have you
made to see if you have even thought
about that already about one out of five
Founders drops off the really I'm
supposed to make money yes that's what a
business is
growth prospects what am I going to say
as a Founder a huge growth
prospects and know they also ask what
makes you unique right what it might be
the form of you know did you get you
have a patent that's one of the favorite
questions is that the protection have
you done this somewhere where it works
can you scale it up right I mean I saw a
Founder who's has a yoga studio she does
really well she wants to open 50 but
it's very personal so the question I
asked was how the heck do you replicate
yourself in 50 other
places try it out it's a great exercise
in thinking about going from somebody
pitching a story because to me this is
what makes for great venture capitalist
they ask the right questions they
separate the impossible the implausible
and the improbable and try to improve
their odds and the comp the stories that
are left over so that's your assignment
for tonight is watch Shark Tank and then
think of yourself as the founder you're
pitching your story to me I don't expect
money to come from me so I'm not a
venture capitalist but I'm going to ask
you question that's basically my job is
to probe your question not because I
think your story is bad but I want you
to make check the weakest links in your
story and think about how you'd protect
yourself so I will see you on Wednesday
um